[Music]
thora birch is an actress
she's been in a lot of movies
like
a lot of movies i'm trying to
find myself let's settle in
and listen to a few tales from some of
thora's most iconic films so whatever i
say just smile and nod
hi my name is laura burch and i've been
acting in film and television since i
was four years old
the beginning of the 90s with hocus
pocus i was kind of cast as the sassy
blonde kid that always had something a
little bit too smart for her own age to
say stuffed face well i remember with
hocus pocus that i i was so thrilled to
have been a part of it to have worked
with bette midler and i fell in love
with kathy and jimmy and sarah jessica
parker
but it came out in an awkward time it
didn't really come out around halloween
and then ten years after that people
would come up to me like hey wait a
second
are you danny from hocus pocus and i'd
be like wait wait what hocus pocus what
are you talking about and then it just
like it my awareness of it growing into
this kind of cult like thing i was like
oh okay wow it's got a long life
what i loved about now and then was it
was about friendships and and how
important they are it's a coming-of-age
movie and and also we had a female
writer we had a female director of
female producers it was very much
female empowerment
for a group of 12 year old girls to be
working on a film like that i didn't
even realize how important it was at the
time
american beauty
i would love to say that i didn't relate
to jane in any way shape or form and
that i was so much more fun-loving and
than she was but no i i there was a
soulful connection to to her malaise but
what i did also respond to specifically
was that through the course of the film
she herself changed the jane at the end
of the film is very different from the
jane that we first meet at the beginning
well for me at the beginning of the 90s
with hocus pocus to the end of the 90s
shooting american beauty it was almost
like being in a different decade
things had changed
that much
but also i grew up and changed that much
having done this since the age of like
four and a half i've learned different
things from different shoots it's not so
much about waiting for one experience
that's going to be like a career
defining thing i think it's just
enjoying the moment and what you're
presented with today
[Music]
you